what are mitochondria
mitochondria are little organelles
they arose they only are found in
eukaryotes u means good karyo
means nucleus so truly like a true
nucleus so
eukaryotes have a nucleus prokaryotes
are before the nucleus they don't have a
nucleus
so eukaryotes have a nucleus
compartmentalization
eukaryotes have also organelles
some eukaryotes have chloroplasts
these are the plants they
photosynthesize
some other eukaryotes like us have
another type of organelle
called mitochondria these
arose from an ancient species
that we engulfed this is an
endosymbiosis
event symbiosis bio means life sim
means together so symbiotes are things
that live together
endosymbiosis endomeans inside so
endosymbiosis means you live together
holding the other one inside you
so the pre-eukaryotes
engulfed an organism
that was very good at energy production
and that organism eventually shed most
of its genome
to now have only 13 genes in the
mitochondrial genome
and those 13 genes are all involved in
energy production
the electron transport chain so
basically
electrons are these massive super energy
rich molecules
we basically have these organelles that
produce energy
and when your muscle exercises you
basically multiply your mitochondria you
basically sort of
you know use more and more mitochondria
and that's how you get beefed up so
basically the ma the muscle sort of
learns how to generate more energy
so basically every single time your
muscles will you know overnight
regenerate and sort of become stronger
and amplify their mitochondrions and so
forth
so what does mitochondria do the
mitochondria
use energy to sort of do any kind of
task
when you're thinking you're using energy
this energy comes from mitochondria
your neurons have mitochondria all over
the place basically this mitochondria
can multiply as organelles
and they can be spread along the body of
your muscle some of your muscle cells
have actually multiple nuclei
they're polynucleated but they also have
multiple mitochondria
to basically deal with the fact that
your muscle is enormous
you can sort of span this super super
long length and you need energy
throughout the length of your muscle
so that's why you have mitochondria
throughout the length and you also need
transcription through the length so you
have multiple nuclei as well
so these two processes
lipids store energy what do mitochondria
do
so there's a process known as
thermogenesis
thermal heat genesis generation
thermogenesis is generation of heat
remember that bathtub with the
in and out that's the equation that
everybody's focused on
so how much energy do you consume how
much energy you burn
but in every thermodynamic system
there's
three parts to the equation there's
energy in
energy out and energy lost
any machine has loss
of energy how do you lose energy you
emanate heat
so heat is energy loss so
um
there's which is where the thermogenesis
comes in thermogenesis
is actually a regulatory process that
modulates the third component of the
thermodynamic equation
you can basically control thermogenesis
explicitly
you can turn on and turn off
thermogenesis and that's where the
mitochondria comes into exactly
so irix 3 and rx5 turn out to be the
master regulators
of a process of thermogenesis versus
lipogenesis generation of fat so irx and
rx5 in most people
burn heat burn burn calories as heat so
when you eat too much
just burn it burn it off in your in your
fat cells so
that bathtub has basically a sort of
dissipation
knob that most people are able to turn
on
i am unable to turn that on because i am
a homozygous carrier
for the mutation that changes a t into a
c
in the rs one four two one zero eight
five allele and locus
a snip i have the risk allele twice from
my mom and for my dad
so i'm unable to thermogenize
i'm unable to turn on thermogenesis
through iric 3 and rx5
because the regulator that normally
binds here r85b can no longer buy
because it's an 80 rich interacting
domain and as soon as i change the t
into a c
it can no longer bind because it's no
longer at rich
but doesn't that mean that you're able
to use the energy more efficiently
you're not generating heat or is it that
means i can eat less
and get around just fine yes yeah so
that's a feature actually it's a feature
in us in a food scarce environment
yeah but if we're all starving i'm doing
great if we all have access to massive
amounts of food
i'm i'm obese basically
you